It is something that's kinda been lost.
And it does make the elders happy
and excited that you're getting out there
and doing what they used to do.
Yeah, this is the end.
End of the line right here.
The fish are all spawned up now.
These are uh, sockeye salmon.
Some of them are still spawning,
you can see eggs and stuff in the water,
but the fish are kinda like this
all over the place up here right now.
I mean they’re in the lake,
they’re in the creeks.
I mean they're everywhere.
You gotta catch them as soon as they get
into the lake basically cause once,
they hit fresh water, they stop feeding
and then they start basically dying.
They start turning red
and their meat starts
to turn white,
and they no longer taste good at all.
And it's like mushy. It's like soft.
They're not good to eat.
For the next couple weeks, they’ll
be fish around just kinda
dying and floating up on the beach.
Can tell that the bears have been coming down
because all the, all the grass is all matted down
and there's dead fish all over the place.
This is kinda their feeding ground.
Let's see what else I can see.
Oh man, look at that.
The bears stashing his fish right here.
It's super fresh too.
And once the bears get full, they’ll
kinda stop eating the whole salmon.
They’ll just start eating like
the good parts, like the belly and stuff.
Think
I'm gonna keep going a little more.
Do a little more exploring. That's a pretty cool find.
It's good just to get out and explore.
Stuff's kinda always changing out here too
you know.
The topography of the land and it's
good to see if the salmon are schooling up
in different places.
How many bears are out and about.
You know, what all the animals
are up to this time of the year. I’m
back here just kinda checking out
where the bears are hanging out.
Where they're at
and about how many there are around.
I mean, there's
there's a lot of bears around here
and they will try to protect
their feeding ground.
That is something you kinda have to
worry about cause we're like right
where they’re eating right now.
I like kinda knowing what they're doing,
where they’re at.
Partially just so you can stay away
from them kind of a thing.
Cause certain years
you'll have more aggressive bears.
Some years
you'll have bears that break into stuff.
But there is that off
chance that you run into that bear
that just wants to eat your face off.
I can hear the bears move around in here
but I can't see ‘em.
I don't like being this low to ‘em.
I’m gonna climb up this hill up here
so I can kinda see what's going on.
Don’t have to have a showdown with a bear.
If I don't have to.
if I don’t have to.
Oh (bleep), that’s a brown bear!
He’s a pretty big bear
growing up out here.
It's burned in to you that you shouldn't
really be afraid of them.
I mean, you should respect them.
But if they do just want to leave
you alone, for the most part,
three bears just came out of the woods.
They’re fighting over a fishing spot.
They're a pretty good size too.
They're coming to check out the salmon
in that creek.
I’m not really worried about the bears,
partially because I have a gun.
They don't really care about you.
Especially right now cause they have like
as much food as they can eat.
This time of year, you can really see
the life cycle of everything.
You know cause the fish are coming
up and everything
kinda seems to feed off the fish somewhat.
There’s just thousands of fish out here.
The seals are coming in to eat the salmon.
I mean the bears are here.
Be nice if I can get out,
catch some pike and maybe shoot a seal
You know, have a little variety.